à carnac l'odeur de la terre à quelque
chose de pas reconnaissable c'est une
odeur de terre peut-être mais passer à
l'échelon de la génomique où le vent le
soleil de sel llyod désossement l'eau
douce des fontaines les coquillages mort
les herbes
le purin la saxifrage lapierre chauffer
les détritus le linge encore mouillé le
goudron débarquer les étables la chaux
des murs les figuiers les vieux
vêtements des gens leur parole est
toujours le vent le soleil le sable
l'humus un peu honteux le goémon sécher
tous ensemble et séparément lutte avec
l'époque des menhirs pour être dimension
gilles guillet rich nous voici donc à
carnac c'est là que nous retrouvons tous
les éléments constants permanents de
votre inspiration
c'est là que vous vous êtes heurter pour
la première fois à cette densité du
monde dont vous essayez depuis de percer
le mystère jaune
j'entends là une cloche en train de dire
que c'est peut-être celle j'ai entendu
bien maintenant bientôt 70 ans
c'est peut-être celle qu'on a fait
sonner l'instrument baptisé dans cette
église qui la côte est je suis né dans
une maison à 100 mètres d'ici dans la
petit louis qu'yvan l'église amusé pyatt
hurle le bourg a changé moins que la
plage
faudrait quand même même s'il a changé
je retrouve le vent la mer le goût chose
guéret ce que chaque lui est particulier
contre société attachée j'ai pas habiter
à carnac
longtemps plaie je suis revenue
régulièrement pour moi c'est l'essentiel
tout le monde n'a pas d'honneur de notre
pays ni aux trois quarts nahd
c'est vraiment l'épaisseur des choses
épaisseur des choses
du milieu des menhirs le monde a l'air
de partir de là d'y revenir
la lumière y est bien pardonne le ciel a
trouvé sa place mais tu vois je me
retrouve ici tout à fait dans mon
paysage d'origine c'est bien sûr le site
et mon monde terraké et je suis heureux
d'être ici avec toi gera casillas oui en
fait bien que né au bord de la mer à
carnac bien que fils de marin bis que
votre père était marin au début vous
êtes quand même un paysan est un paysan
pauvre
oui d'ailleurs les familles de mont
vernon mer étaient des gens on peut même
appeler ça les paysans tellement il a tu
es pauvre en terre et je suis partie de
ce paysage évidemment aussi bien sur le
plan politique au second plan au monde
éthiques
je crois que c'est aussi cette terre qui
m'a amené à vouloir vie plus riche plus
grande ouverte
je crois que c'est le lac parti m'a vue
sur le monde nous besoin de changer ce
monde société pour arriver à une société
fraternelle en isère
beaucoup d'hommes sont venus sont restés
terre d'ossements poussière d'ossements
il y avait donc l'appel de carnac
comment chanter t-il ceux des menhirs
peut-être est-ce là qu'ils avaient moins
peur centre du ciel et de la mer de la
terre aussi la lumière le dit j'entends
eux pas loin de la mer pour être admis
par la lumière regardant la mer lui tour
dans le doubs implorant la terre on vous
avait toujours parlé de manière et je me
demande aussi ses menhirs sont pour vous
un mystère on comptera une familiarité
les deux vous avez dit que nous étions
dans l'avenir nous sommes parmi les pays
où l'on rêve moi ç'a toujours été d'être
dans la pierre alors on peut se projeter
j'ai aussi écrit des pages appelées rock
ou jeudi si je peux dire
j'essaie de lire l'avis des rock mais
viseront tout cela n'est toujours qu'un
travail
il ya aussi le rêve de solidité votre
recherche de toujours devant toujours
être solide ggyc toute la vie je suis
anti bush a toujours très fragile et 13
mars et les gens me disent que moi je
suis une phrase la nature je me vois pas
comme ça il y à des milliers d'années
que les menhirs de tnt et à ceux vendus
leur jeu
entre le bourg et la plage
il y avait sur la droite une fontaine
qui n'en finissait pas de remonter le
temps
cette fontaine eugène guillevic doit
vous paraître rassurante elle donne
cette impression de stabilité que vous
me semblez toujours recherchés dans
votre plaisir est pour moi la fontaine
et quelque chose d'apaisant c'est
évidemment le cas le repos le
recueillement au sursaut mais c'est
aussi et très mystérieuse j'écoute pour
moi il ya aussi mystérieux que l'eau
justement qu'il ne bouge pas le lauquet
parle moi je dirais pas juste de l'eau
qui dort je crois pas qu'elle garde
je crois que l'on ne dort pas nous à
savoir toujours être une interrogation
sur soi même mais une interrogation à
loisir réservation et son tourment cette
monarchie 6 2 qui se projette dans l'eau
nous pond la fontaine et aussi comme une
ouverture sur origin de quoi de tout du
monde
enfin des gens n'auront qu'un paravent à
remonter le temps eu qu'à l'origine
avec les fontaines au fin fond des
terres nous avons été
avec les fontaines sous le poids des
algues nous avons été c'était contre
l'ess et probablement pour ne plus
parler
vous évoquez souvent cette rencontre en
forme d'affrontement qui lie à ici à
carnac entre la mer les marais d'une
part et d'autre part la terre c'est une
lutte des éléments lutte sans solution
s'il y en a une c'est violent c'est
c'est dans le poème cet om qui règlent
des règles qui il ya la solution qu'il a
qui est l'aboutissement des choses on
m'a dit que dans carnac moi c'est pas
fait exprès redit que la mer est
l'élément féminin internautes masculins
possible j'en sais rien
le maire c'est une puissance tout le
poivre
et à un moment donné ils se produisent
une sorte d' équilibre bel équilibre et
paie un équilibre un peu solide et
inquiétant non ce monde se montrer comme
ça non le monde
pour moi le monde toujours inquiétant le
monde plein de tension le monde va
monter tragique
la lutte des éléments ne s'arrête jamais
et il ya un équilibre précaire
il a maille à parier que la terre existe
encore durer après l'échec du à travers
des tragédiens se sentent les menhirs la
nuit vont et viennent et se grignotent
les forêts le soir font du bruit en
mangeant la mer mais son gréement autour
du cou et 16 et patou froid pousse
l'homme supply chain et c'est il ya un
quatrième élément qui est j'ai dit eric
lui-même acquis à l'air aussi de
chercher son équilibre ben oui faut que
j'assure nous sommes nous même que des
et composée de tous ces éléments
éternellement va garer nous sommes nous
mêmes le lieu de paccar et une bagarre
le repos n'existe qu'en terme
je suis confus
c'est à dire que cet équilibre instable
se défait à chaque moment et il faut le
retrouver
je crois que le but si on peut parler de
but le finalité du poème d'ailleurs
c'est justement comme un porc
ou la durée s'arrête le poème est à un
moment verticale par rapport à la durée
à l'aide du mouvement al ain al a donc
duré dix lutte se déroule dans le temps
certains que j'ai reçus sin leçon
geneviève façon voir le ca d'un
classicisme moulin j'ai toujours dit que
j'ai vécu plus dans la préhistoire que
dans l'histoire c'est mon jeu pendant la
prise de position politique
ce qui est sûr c'est que les landes de
monsieur de châteaubriant ne sont pas du
tout celles de guéric nom bien sont des
landes de pauvre taylor à quoi tu aereo
ce monde terraké comme on dit
je n'ai pas eu mon chum y est comme job
pour dire ce qui manque pour que vienne
la fête mais j'ai eu ce paysage
mais vous qui connaîtrait l'autre
travaille plus tard
alors qu'il sera devenu comme une fête
quand il sera ce qu'est le poème au
poète pour chacun sa passion sa victoire
son art
pensez alors à nous avec un peu l'écart
c'est vrai que d'avoir tant traîné comme
des bêtes à des travaux qu'on l'exécuté
qu'on répète la tristesse a bien pu
marquer notre regard à comprenez que
nous avons aimé la vie et malgré ça
s'étend ferla azules envie d'abandonner
l'espoir et de pleurer chez vous oui
nous avons aimé terriblement la joie la
moindre est grande joie au moins autant
que vous et la plus grande était de vous
ouvrir la voie
on